[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 31st of
August I'm John Connolly The Spectators
news editor and your host this week
coming up on the show
Douglas Murray asks in his column why
museums seem so desperate to give up
their collections George Osborne wants
to send the Elgin marbles back to Greece
could the Benin bronzers be next he'll
join me
is it going to be India Century James
Hill writes this week's cover piece
about how Rishi sunac wants to bind
Britain to the country with the biggest
population in the world James will join
me with Ravi agraval
sunac has had a mini reshuffle this week
to replace Ben Wallace his party though
is still 20 points behind in the polls
she'll be taking more risks to win over
the public Katie balls will be on the
show
on a braveman this week told police that
they need to investigate every crime why
isn't this happening already I'll speak
to Ian ageson and finally Kate Andrews
says Brits don't go to the doctor enough
she'll join me
before we get going if you like
spectator TV do subscribe to our YouTube
channel spectator TV is picking up
thousands of new subscribers every week
and you should be one of them just click
the Subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the Bell icon so you
never miss an episode
first up Douglas Moyer writes about
George Osborne's plan to return the
Elgin marbles to Greece in this week's
magazine why is it that more and more
Museum directors seem to hate the
collections they're looking after
Douglas joins me now
Douglas thank you for joining us on
spectator TV you're out in the magazine
this week about a particular Affliction
that seems to affect tourism middle age
and how you always suspected George
Osborne was going to succumb to it so uh
can you tell us a bit about that please
and why why you think George Osborne was
a prime candidate for a midlife crisis
yes it's a fascinating uh part of
political anthropology that there is a
type of conservative particularly
conservative male it has to be said who
in middle age has a sort of breakdown
about their beliefs and uh I know see
also met Hancock
um and uh usually they this expresses
itself in a loss of belief in the things
that they have argued for hitherto and
usually the adoption of a
um right on cause as they see it
ordinarily it manifests in uh requests
or the legalization of marijuana or
drugs
um and that's the most common one
um Crispin blunt this is a good example
as well
um and the I think the explanation is
the certain type of conservative has
been so used to espousing relatively
unpopular or uncool opinion that they
hope that if they do something sort of
Grand in middle age it'll make up for it
and wash all of these sins away I say
that George Osborne has long been a
prime candidate for this
um George Osborne of course gets all of
the attacks and brick backs of the left
I think rather unfairly I mean they
literally accuse him being a murderer uh
of killing people through austerity
which of course was was not really
austerity at all but anyway he he
suffered a lot of unpopularity perhaps
culminating in that famous Boo in the
stadium in the London Olympics which
must have been very uh uh upsetting to
it uh but I I predicted that that he
would be the sort of conservative who
who would end up having a midlife crisis
and he would have to espouse some right
on cause and the moment that he took
over as chair uh chairman of the
trustees of the British museum I thought
ah I see this one coming
he's arranged so this is manifested he's
arranged alone for the Elgin marbles can
you tell us a bit about that why is it
such a bad deal for example to give the
Greeks the Elgin marbles for a little
while uh well I mean first of all as I
say it's a totally predictable thing uh
if you become a chair of the trustees
the British Museum and your conservative
uh you will feel disproportionate uh
desire to send the Elgin Marble uh to
Greece uh it would it would it's so
tempting uh as this wonderful
demonstration of right hollery
um and of course George Osborne we've
learned has been uh negotiating this
return I I say that
um in the in the magazine I say I think
it's a rather unwise uh deal a deal
that's so cat-handed in fact so far as
we know that it could have been
negotiated by an Austin Powers villain
um it's it it's it's apparently a deal
that that the British museum sends uh
the marbles uh to Athens and in return
Athens sends some Treasures that have
never before been seen in uh the UK
um that's very nice of them I'm sure but
I would have thought that it's the
likelihood of the marbles being returned
is exceptionally small as Noel Malcolm
of uh or Souls among others has said
this week it would only require one
Greek citizen to go to court and insist
marbles must not be returned to the UK
and um that would hold it up on its own
and goodness knows that person might
even find the Greek courts are slightly
sympathetic to their case uh so um it
isn't a very wise uh a deal it seems to
me and although people deny it uh
there's just no doubt that when it comes
to this alleged returning of treasures
um you start off with one and you go
straight on to the other uh the Benin
bronzes have long been uh or at least
for some years have been regarded as
sort of stolen loot which most of them
are not uh and uh the obar of Benin has
been getting more press recently than at
any time since the late 19th century and
the billion bronzes will of course be
next and then you just go down down the
list there's a call through Egypt for
the Rosetta Stone to be sent there
um it just won't end and as I say it's
it's a demonstration of of a type of
weakness but a type of weakness that
really only the Tory male in midlife is
capable of
and you mentioned the piece as well
Douglas that all this seems to be going
on there's some sort of obsession with
giving the marbles back and decolonizing
the museum comes at a time when the
British museum is facing a bit of a
crisis in terms of the theft of yes
missing items do you think they've been
distracted essentially from their main
functions yes that's right I'm uh almost
2 000 artifacts appear to have been uh
um stolen from the British museum under
the noses of of the director and
trustees it's extraordinary uh a member
of Staff has been fired and and the
Museum's director has resigned
um but we've subsequently learned that
even two years ago uh a Danish expert
wrote to the British museum saying that
artifacts from the British museum were
finding their way into onto the market
even being put on eBay and so having
been alerted to this two years ago the
British museum appears not to have acted
at all and thought that actually
everything was fine I wonder if this
isn't the time to extend one of my own
laws I might histrionically call it
Murray's law
which is this in the same way that we
now know that when a an energy company
goes on about how green they are we know
that they're polluters
um and in the same way that we now know
that when a bank goes sort of huge on
BLM or something they're actually
corrupt or that when a financial
services uh firm decides to go huge on
ESG Dei and all the other stuff it's
because they're not giving good returns
to their customers we should I think
start to assume that when museums like
the British museum end up obsessing over
their their collection as if they're
stolen goods actually they are not in
charge of the collection in the way they
should be actually they are not
protecting and preserving The Collection
which is after all their sole job I
think we should expect
in such cases the moment that a museum
director or curator starts talking about
getting rid of the collection is if it's
a set of hot stolen goods off the back
of a truck we should assume that they
actually do not have the ability to do
the basics of looking after the core of
the collection yeah I mean see you
mentioned the museum director there
who's who's recently resigned I mean he
was behind moving the bust of Han Sloan
from a different part of the museum
because it was linked to the slave trade
I mean do you ever get the sense of why
do these people in particular take these
jobs if they resent their collections so
much
you're so right I mean exactly the the
um the director who did that of course
you know
totally tokenistic and pointless and
actually rather insulting uh gestures
like the movement of the of the bust uh
become a sort of cover as I say for sort
of inadequacies at best uh elsewhere I
think you can see this in collection
after collection I've written about this
in the magazine before most obvious
example is the welcome trust but I would
I would I would suggest that people
should do a serious audit on the
governance of Tate uh Britain among
others I've written about this in the
magazine before but Tate Britain uh is
is run by people who seem to hate the
collection in their care and keep
insulting the artists whose work they
are in they are meant to be preserving
for future Generations most notably uh
Tate written has been uh has closed the
Rex Whistler mural room insulted Rex
Whistler who died fighting the Nazis
um also insulted Stanley Spencer and
degraded him as some kind of racist I
think that all all of the people in
charge of the collection of tape written
should be should be fired I think they
have no right to be in charge of a great
National Collection but that's that's
the difference that seems to exist today
there was a period where to be on a
board like that of Tate of Britain was
to know that you had a guardianship for
a short time of one of the great
collections in the country and indeed in
the world it takes a certain type of
extraordinary what would you call it um
not just hubris but a kind of arrogance
to think to dare to think that your job
is not to preserve the collection but to
stand in judgment over that's that's a
standing judgment over how it was put
together and who contributed to it and
who the artists are and whether or not
they live up to your glorious self
um to hell with these people uh they
they have no right to be in charge of
our great collections many of them
clearly demonstrably uh uh unfit for the
task
um and I and I I had any upright would
like to see them replaced uh by people
who actually venerate the collections
and regard it as being an honor as it is
to be in charge of such Treasures
brilliant thank you very much Douglas
it's a great pleasure next James Hill
writes in a magazine this week about
Rishi sunak's plan to get close to India
but as India want closer ties with
Britain James joins me now with Ravi
agraval editor-in-chief of foreign
policy magazine
James and Ravi thank you for joining us
on spectator TV
um James you're out in the cool piece
this week that when Rishi sunak goes to
India next week for the G20 goes to New
Delhi it's gonna be quite a moment uh
can you tell us about can you tell us
why in a bit of the background here
well of course yes I mean I think that
it will be a big moment for the history
of anglo-indian relations stretching
back four centuries first time I've had
a prime minister of Asian Heritage going
over and some meeting uh two Hindu heads
of government and it's going to be a
really big moment I think because this
is going to be I think a future
Cornerstone of Britain's post-brexit
policy under lestrasse and Boris Johnson
I think there was often a case perhaps
that trade deals were pursued
um you know for the moment of proving
that Britain could sign these deals and
their own sake but I think this is much
more under a sunak it's perhaps seemed
much more part of a strategy of tilting
to the indo-pacific and really trying to
encourage those economic ties at the
same time as building a security
relationship as well
um and so I think that along with you
know the G20 moment India is hoping to
Showcase itself to the world there's
also going to be lots of talks behind
the scenes going on I've had about 12 I
think a ministerial visits or so this
past 12 months and that really shows how
much emphasis Britain is putting in a
ministerial level on fostering these
ties and as I ran the piece India's
going to be one of the two biggest
economies by 2050 on current trends and
it's going to be a relationship I think
that's only going to seem more and more
important in the future decades to come
Ravi you know James mentions there that
part of syrac strategy is about sort of
hitching Britain to the wagon of what
what could be like the next global
economic superpower I mean do you agree
with that strategy do you think now is
the right time to try and Ally with with
India
I think it is I mean as long as one
keeps in mind that India is a
longer-term bet
um of all the things that seem Dynamic
about India whether it is its young
population whether it's rising GDP uh
whether it's the increased consumption
capacity of being in middle class all of
those things are based on projections in
the future and India continuing its
current growth rate
um and so it's a longer term Ploy I
don't think anyone who tries to sort of
milk a relationship with India in the
short term is going to succeed whether
you're a company or a country but in as
much as you know this lays some of the
groundwork for a future
post-brexit uh British sort of global
trade agenda it only makes sense to to
Hitch one's wagon to India for the
longer term and James you know that the
free trade deal there with that's been
mentioned I mean for Britain how much of
this is economic or how much of it is
just about building ties or is it a bit
of both
I think it's a bit of both really I
think that you know clearly it was a big
economic disrupture a big economic
disruptor to leave the European Union uh
seven years ago and so what this is
about really is always you know trying
to find those new markets and new
developments and obviously I think you
look at the foreign office it's couched
a lot of this stuff in that you know
demographic terms so looking to the
Future as Robbie says I'm sort of
betting on the fact that you know by all
metrics it seems in the Pacific is going
to be the key region for growth in both
people and economics as well in the
future
um but also as I think it's starting to
lay the groundwork for future terms I
think you know talking to people you
know in and around the foreign office
has perhaps been a sense that India
hasn't really learned in over the past
couple of decades perhaps in the
foremost of Britain's strategy as it
perhaps it could or should have been and
now it's sort of trying to kind of put
some of that right and a recognition
that India has a tradition of on trade
of being it was quite protectionist for
the first four decades after
Independence that sort of changed from
the 1990s but it's a country where there
haven't been that many great trade deals
you know really deep trade deal struck
and so this is a sort of attempt to try
and move some of that and I think really
at the Strategic level is the Hope is
that India could certainly be developed
more as a long-term Ally
um given its tradition as I say of
protectionism and online movement during
the Cold War as well
what do you get the census of of India's
perspective on this I mean it's becoming
quite important in the UK but is it kind
of a sideshow in India or do you think
do you think they do want better
relations with Britain
I think it's a bit of both I think you
know as James was just mentioning uh you
know India is still fairly protectionist
um India doesn't see itself as
non-aligned anymore
um but it tries to use the phrase
strategic autonomy instead it has a very
transactional foreign policy it has a
transactional trade policy it likes to
pick and choose allies in sort of an A
La Carte manner if you kind of imagine
that the world map as a giant Buffet
um and and that that's sort of how India
seeks to conduct its foreign policy now
especially under Prime Minister Modi and
you one has to imagine that he will
remain in power after next year's
elections as well
um so this is an enduring foreign policy
as well
um but in terms of importance uh I do
get the sense that this uh visit is much
more important for the United Kingdom
than it is for India
um I think India of course is seeing uh
the G20 Summit as its moment in the sun
it is seeing its own position as being
enhanced on the global stage as a voice
of the global South it's very keen to
try and project itself as a leader among
developing countries and I think that
really is the most important thing for
New Delhi this month and in several
months to come whether it's climate
change negotiations whether it's asking
for more compensation payments at cop28
uh in in in Dubai later this year
whether it is striking uh separate deals
with the United States or other
countries on specific Tech or defense
issues India is very much picking and
choosing how it wants to make friends uh
anywhere in the world and I think the UK
is part of that agenda one other key
thing that has changed over the last few
years is China I think India has really
reoriented its foreign policy from
thinking uh less about Pakistan these
days and much more about China whether
it is conducting trade with China
whether it's border issues whether it's
diversifying its military and defense
ties it is currently diversifying away
from Russia more towards Western
countries France and the U.S
specifically but this is where the UK
fits in as well because as the UK
reorients itself away from China which
by the way was a sticking point for
India five or six years ago but as the
UK becomes less likely to want to do
trade with China as it decouples in a
sense or de-risks it becomes a more
attractive potential partner for India
so there is that uh looming in the
background as always that's a very
interesting point I mean James Marshall
sends from the UK government side do
they very much see India as a potential
bull walk against China
yeah I'm not sure they would necessarily
be so explicit about the language but I
think that is a sort of the unspoken
feature of a lot of conversations you
look today we've had the Foreign Affairs
committee release a report they're
talking about different measures by
which the UK can strengthen itself and
sort of in that relationship against
China and I think you know the obvious
Point here is that why couldn't India be
built up
um and really try and develop this over
those markets so I was talking to you
know one MP who made point for instance
why are we we've got universities which
are so financially dependent on Chinese
students replacing that with you know
Indian students students from a
democracy seems like an obvious uh
substitute which could help other things
for instance looking at kind of ways to
work with the Indian Navy in the future
as well so I think that the thing that
obviously China is going to be the kind
of key threat um whether or not racinex
ministers would actually say so
explicitly on Ultra remains to be seen
but it's going to be a key factor in the
UK policy making for the 2020s 2013s and
40s and interestingly I think labor
actually at the times have been even
more cynoskeptic on this issue than the
Tories have so I think that will
continue after the next election
um as Robbie says I think that Modi will
presumably will be re-elected next year
but Richard Knight doesn't look like it
on current trends so I think this is
going to be a really long-term debate
and and I what I would point to are the
comments made by Britain's own man in
New Delhi um Alex Ellis the High
Commissioner and he gave a speech I
think it was uh two years ago having
also co-authored that uh Strategic
Defense review of 2021 which talked
about the end of Pacific tilt he he said
that in his lifetime India America and
China with three great powers and I
think that really it brings us looking
at the region and thinking well that's
what we can to work with you know India
which is still an ally rather than
basically make sure that China assumes a
real hegemonic lead over this and
dominates the Indian Ocean in the
indo-pacific region
and and James you mentioned that the
issue of student visas is probably
something we should come back to which
is the wider issue of Indian visas when
it comes to the trade deal and you
mentioned them in your piece there's a
potential sticking point the British
side can you can you tell us a bit about
that
yeah sure so I mean there's Dean we're
now in the 13th round of negotiations
um on the free trade agreement between
the UK and India uh they started uh in
January last year
um so long time but by kind of Standards
doing with India
um some of the ones with Australia I
think took on and off best part of a
decade and so that's part of the course
and really it's been affected first of
all by concerns politically with the
conservative party here in the UK
um so Boris Johnson and this trust both
wants to get a deal done by Diwali um
and that was seen as a weakening I think
in the UK now I've seen as weekend in
the UK negotiating hand because if you
have a deadline and say we're going to
get there no matter what what's the
other incentive what's the incentive of
the other side to negotiate
um so it's affected that part but as you
say um student visas has been an
interesting part of this which is that a
lot of the conservative party are
skeptical about high levels of migration
um okay bad knock I think it's a
publicly last December that this that
the they didn't want any more student
visas and that's a a key part of part of
the conversation here really because you
know the UK wants to reduce tariffs I
think that you know site and Stat in the
article which says that only three
percent of UK um Indian Goods to the UK
have tariffs coming through so just
three percent but vice versa at 60 so
they want those reduced tariffs um but
at the same time that India's looking
for things like music concessions so for
instance on the fact that people who
come have to pay National Insurance and
don't see the benefits of that and also
um also there's been discussions around
student visas as well so all the things
have to be ironed out and that's why I
think although I say that you know
ministers are you know very keen to have
strike a deal with India
um I don't I can't see one necessarily
being signed sort of imminently and
that's why I think that as I try to
stress in the piece is that as much as
official ties are important and things
like the Free Trade Agreement it's also
unofficial ties as well and the fact
that British Indians are the largest
ethnic minority group in this country
with 1.8 million and that's why
unofficial ties are as likely to pay a
part in the future coming decades
between Britain and India and rather to
hear your view what's the sort of Indian
perspective on Visa liberal
liberalization I mean how important is
to to Modi and his government that that
bring allows more visas for example for
for Indian Nationals in in the UK
it's really important um I think for
quite a while now India's Tech sector
has kind of cornered the market not just
in the UK but around the world in the US
as well
um for specialized visas and what they
often do is they send in workers on
highly skilled visas uh to take on
specific I.T projects so these are often
short-term visas anywhere from three
months to three years and if you look at
most western industrialized countries
those types of visas that are given out
tend to be dominated by Indians they
also tend to get booked out almost as
soon as they they are up for grabs such
as the demand for them and it's
symbiotic of course because all of these
Western economies they do rely on
companies that are based in India such
as by the way emphasis which prime
minister synecas uh has a sort of stake
in a sense through his wife but but
these companies have made huge inroads
into the west and they also have the ear
of the Indian government and so there's
a fair bit of lobbying pressure in New
Delhi
um to try and ensure that these
companies are able to continue their uh
growing their presence in countries like
the UK and the U.S and remember these
are these are highly weighted companies
uh on the Bombay Stock Exchange
um so of course there's a there's a link
back to the Indian private sector and
general economic sentiment and of course
I think for younger Indians we can't
um we can't overstate the importance of
their mobility and their ability to to
go to other countries it is very
difficult to get a British visa to get a
work visa in the UK or the us if you're
an Indian Citizen and so New Delhi is
very incentivized to try and make those
processes easier tie them into bigger
deals as and when they can so that they
can push them through all right thank
you Ravi thank you James
Katie ball says that Rishi sunak needs
to take some risks in a politics column
this week is the PM's plan to stick to
his five pledges going to win the public
over Katie joins me now
Katie thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um now you're writing your column this
week that Richardson was looking for
certain qualities in his next defense
secretary now turns out that bemos is
gone he's been replaced by Grant shaps
um do you think grandchilds has those
qualities and he's then he's up to the
job more generally yeah but the
qualities that they're about four but
particularly it's non-flashy I think
ground chefs can try and be quite flashy
sometimes
um but the most important thing from the
conversation I had Richard wrote about
in the column was a day of someone who
is loyal and and I think that Grant
chefs does tick that box
um because when they were picking the
next defense secretary it was ultimately
suggesting me some hard-working not
particularly so not particularly unique
attributes but I think if you've read
between the lines
um you could obviously see a situation
whereby I think what they were trying to
say is you're not going to get a very
showy person who's perhaps the type of
candidate journalist might get more
excited about
um more Dynamic and a bit more
unpredictable instead they were going to
play it quite safe and I think grandchup
does reflect that and a very experienced
cabinet minister lots of briefs he is
actually the shortest ever serving Home
Secretary from his brief stint um
because that has just got that under his
belt but it was obviously served in lots
of different Tory governments of course
she have had a couple at this point and
I think that um therefore if you're
looking at why they picked him I mean I
think there's probably two main factors
I think the most important comes down to
defense spending and the fact that they
did not want to pick someone who might
have you know ideas about the defense
budget about the pleasure next election
about um what you do about the gaping
holes in the current equipment the
military has because so much has been
sent to Ukraine and and if you think
back to the summer Leadership contest
Liz trust was saying three percent of
GDP for defense spending Rishi Scenic
would never go that high even in the
contest and when he took over from her
he scaled back down the defense spending
so at the moment it's 2.5 percent of GDP
is a target over a you know a longer
period of time and I think they wanted
to avoid the type of Tesla you got for
example if you think back to the Theresa
May era if we remember private Pike that
was the nickname for Gavin Williamson
when he embarked on this big uh you know
defense spending war with Philip Hammond
and therefore Grant chaps is very
unlikely to do that and then secondly I
think that the reason it is Grand chaps
and not another student loyalist is
because he's seen as a competent media
performer and if we think back to the
Boris Johnson era he was one who did the
infamous Barnard Castle shift
um when Dominic Cummings goes caught in
trouble and which was a pretty
uncomfortable media round but I think it
does just reflect how he has seen also
by Rishi Suna because someone you can
send out and they will stick to the line
now of course this does mean that
perhaps you're getting a less Dynamic
defense secretary and someone said Ben
Wallace was and someone who's
continuatory favor it
um but that is clearly not what they
decided to go for I mean obvious
comparisons in terms of resignations
um we had Nadine Doris ago who released
a scathing letter about the Prime
Minister and then you had Ben Wallace
this week who's actually quite an
amicable departure do you think it's
been handled quite well his his
resignation yeah I think that behind the
scenes there have been tensions between
benoits and Rishi sumag um Ben Wallace
was very much a Boris Johnson man and he
endorsedler's trust not Rishi sunak and
partly I think because of the difference
in their defense spanning pledges but I
think if you are loyal to Boris Johnson
you're often also a little bit scared to
The Cove Rishi Cena you see that you
know not on the Doris Level but on a
level
um and I think the spending demands and
the back and forth is something which
which did cause friction
um I think there's also some in the mod
close to Ben Wallace who questioned why
when you talk about the five priorities
nothing to do defenses in them because
if you look at polling for example you
have a situation whereby I think
not every poll but for example there was
a recent
um a poll looking a you know different
policy areas the only area where
neighbor are trusted less than the
Tories was handling Ukraine so why not
make more something of it but I think
where we've got to in the end is he has
left him pretty amicable terms and if I
think there are issues of defense
spending in the past I wouldn't rule out
then Wallace coming out of the woodwork
and making a statement and but I think
it's it's gone probably as well as
Richard Cena could have hoped for we
should mention as well uh clerkatsinio
has stepped into Grand Chap's role as
Secretary of State for Net Zero and
energy security
um what did you make of her appointment
do you think it's a good choice uh well
I think it's an interesting choice
um in the sense that she's the first of
the 2019 intake to uh you know to
receive that high information to join
the cabinet
um I suppose for journalists if we're
looking from that perspective it's
probably a bit more interesting than
Grant chaps just because it is a fresh
face in the cabinet and this is again a
sunette lawyer this I don't know if you
can really get more loyal to Richard
Cena in the sense that she served us as
PPS
um when she became an MP but prior to
that she was actually his special
advisor when he was in the treasury and
so we've known each other a very long
time she's a former banker and I think
they think quite similarly on quite a
few issues
um and therefore you know it's a big
jump in terms of uh seniority on that
brief
but I think having you know women in her
30s on the energy brief at a time and
NetZero is just such a potentially
divisive
issue within the Tory party labor also
and the country and does suggest that I
think you know she she is
treasury-minded in many ways but she's
also someone who has been a member of
the conservative environment Network so
I think it's trying to ultimately appeal
to
um you know both sides so at that
appointment so it's always a safe Choice
again
um you write in your column this week
that Richard sulac's very keen not to
sort of go down the reset routes and
shake things up now his party there is
still 20 points behind in the polls I
mean do you think that's the right
strategy what's what do you make of that
so I think they hate the word reset
because it tends to uh ultimately
the admission of failure previously why
do you have to reset it suggests you
know something went wrong of your own
making and if you think about the
various Boris Johnson resets and
remember there being a big speech after
he narrowly won a confidence vote and a
narrow in the confidence that clear win
it doesn't really feel like that when
you have that many MPS against you and
this feature was a bit all over the
place and the MPS were a bit unsure you
know a messaging Johannes are saying
more evidence so I don't think they want
to have an official reset for those
reasons I think there is a sense that
the first stage of British today's
Premiership is coming to an end and it's
you know coming in initially trying to
calm things down both in terms of the
economy but also the Tory party and all
honesty and therefore if you do still
have that big pole Gap what can you do
to fill it now you're often hear members
where she see next team say it's going
to be really radical we're going to
shake things up and I think there's a
question which is is a rishi's radical
someone else's level of radical yeah or
if in a quite a
risk-averse logical politician and
perhaps you know I don't know if it's
Dominic Cummings levels of radical
um but I think we are going to see you
know more attack they're definitely
sharpening up the political operation I
think as an effort to bring back some
old faces and in terms of the number 10
building so you have one Aid um coming
back from the Cameron era I think the
during the cameras that felt there was a
really um efficient attack operation so
to try and bring a bit more discipline
in that sense
um and lots more kind of going for kids
Dharma I think his record from his time
as DPP and then you just have you know
these big set pieces that were always
going to be there so Party Conference
The King's Speech and the Autumn
statement and the question is what can
you do with them to suggest that this
government you know and the words of the
dean Doris is not a zombie government
and I think that's his challenge but
um I could be wrong but increasingly I
think you know rishi's next version of
radical unit I think we all are going to
see a different change of pace it just
it might be as we've seen from their
appointments that we just discussed
system not as Extreme as Summoners party
would like uh given the state of things
Home Secretary swella braveman this week
told police to investigate every crime
why weren't they doing this already
though it's pleasing too focused on
wishy-washy identity politics former
prison Governor Ian HSN joins me now
Ian thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um swella Braverman has said this week
that the police need to investigate
every crime and particular theft
um what did you make of that
announcement were you surprised to hear
her say this or I guess a lot of people
watching maybe think that the police you
know were meant to be investigating
every crime
well you would say that and thanks for
having all uh Joel you've said that when
he is that the public would react like
that but I think the experience
unfortunately of the public is that they
realize that the police uh are not
resourced or equipped and sometimes
don't have the will or uh to investigate
all crimes
um you know crimes have disproportion of
the impact on people so you know my
partner it might be an inconvenience to
me it might be devastating and
life-changing some of the who's got Pure
resources it is a repeat victim so you
know I I was interested in uh the public
secretary uh coming out to say the
police investing in all the crime I was
I was more interested I guess in the the
impertinence of the police Chiefs
counselor then tried to lecture on uh
not getting involved in in operational
matters you'd say that you know the
political heads of the home office uh
would have every reason on behalf in
citizens to make sure that the police
are are performing as the people who pay
for them would expect
yeah it's quite shocking I mean if you
look at some of the stats around like
the the number of thefts so
um investigated and solved for example
it's it's pretty woeful stuff I mean do
the police Chiefs have any point what
what's what's the reason these these
figures are so low basically
well I you know I I think there has been
a um an environment where uh police
Chiefs have had to you know been put in
a very invidious position uh you you
know what the facts are as well as Idol
I've written about it for for coffee
house enough and that is you know uh
between 2000 and about 10 and 17 uh
austerity Service uh across the country
lost 22 000 officers those officers only
uh you know quite recently being
replaced and there's a question about
the the type of officers that are
replacing those who left meanwhile
you've got a recorded crime at its
highest level ever I believe somewhere
at seven billion recorded crimes the
last time the uh obviously Nation
statistics were besides so so there is a
a mismatch
in volume versus capacity with the
police that that will always you know be
a factor about how much resource you can
throw out something that isn't likely
ever to be sold but I think the net
effect
uh has been that is it's been an excuse
ready for police to withdraw from
communities and to withdraw from
investigating certain types of crime but
how they disproportionate impact on
poorer communities so what I mean by
that is you know where you have uh shops
or uh in poor areas
um that you know provide a vital
community service where uh shopkeepers
are afraid to open up because of repeats
offending Often by people who are uh
shoplifting because of an addiction to
uh to drugs and so on but where they see
no response it's so demoralizing for
being you're providing art service that
they decide to shut down and that's not
just you know uh your corner shop is it
it's also we've seen recently the co-op
saying that they're considering closing
shops because there's been no response
to by the police so
um you know outrageous levels of of
theft from shops and that's really
dangerous because I think when you see
those communities in London there's so
much stress and pressure already having
Services further what's Driven you're
into a bit of a death spiral but of
course the one thing that we know and we
know from the United States we know from
uh you know in the United Kingdom is
that the people who are
disproportionately affected by reduction
in police presence or base Effectiveness
are poor people so you know the people
that live uh somewhere different to
middle class criminologists to you know
have dominated this this debate uh for
far too long so I think we do need to
get back to uh assertive police
intervention uh particularly in
communities that have been donated from
from neighborhood policing and this is
another Point uh job that I would say
that yes there should be a focus as
bizarre as it signs where the Home
Secretary say police investigate all
prime
but where we have uh the destination of
neighborhood policing and where we have
trusted and available and consistent
police presence as being withdrawn
because police Chiefs again are up in
the position where they have to uh
produce a an emergency service for
life-threatening emergencies but that
has to be at the expense of something
else where there's an abstraction of
community and neighborhood policing
you're getting these problems that are
growing and growing with no solution to
them uh until they you're saying they
burst into the headlines and the co-op
says actually we can run a shop here
because people are just you know robbing
the place blind and the police aren't
interested so what we should have is a
Renaissance in my opinion of community
policing and again I've written about
this quite extensively uh where uh the
bribe was taken back where Authority is
restored in places where you you
normally we see a piping attendant for
God's sick you know uh rather than a
police officer and problems that are
driving sort of you know the lower level
offenses that don't seem to be
investigated uh get addressed in a
preventative way so that they don't get
out of control because what we have to
have in these communities are are places
where people feel that they are able to
bring up families
uh and at the moment I think in some of
these communities you get people who are
stuck because if they don't have the
resources to move out
so with all these places that are
suffering uh disproportionately from
low-level crime incidentally and other
social behavior to to
um the only singing about moving out of
them we want to make them better for
them and I think yeah I would say to to
Michael Gove obviously um leveling up
secretary that you know that this issue
is a leveling up priority
you know security of of citizens to live
in Aryans you know he wants uh you know
the you know these areas to be livable
uh spaces well I think the police on
Prime control particularly are on low
level instability and artificial
behavior is a key priority for him and
his Department to create these
communities for people you know can go
out after Dark
but do you think the police need more
resources to do this because I mean I
imagine police forces would say you know
we would love to put more Bobbies on the
beat we'd love to be out in the
community much more but the moment we're
tackling very serious crimes and massive
Rises and sexual offenses for example do
you sort of buy that do you think they
need more more money more more police
officers than they have now I know the
numbers have been increased again but
but do you think they need more than
that
I think we have to be very careful about
the discourse that says we sold money at
the problem and it will fix it because
you know look at the NHS for example
which has gone billions and billions
investors and it's still um in terms of
productivity way behind the curve uh
where it should be so you know the
policing uh numbers are being restored
um that to be fair to um
previous homosexuals and previous Prime
Ministers that was a pledge and has
apparently been met so this deficit of
22 000 police officers has been has been
met
but I think culturally
um something else is going on as well
that that speaks to to leadership
because we don't have the same problem
of course all police uh constabularies
there are some like a submissions that
are like performing others
um you know and where they've had very
you know typical Wicked problems to
solve uh greater Manchester police for
example it was in special measures is
that other special measures because
they've got a chief police officer uh
stegan Watson who wants to be focused on
the priorities that matter to the public
well you know policing hurty words and
nonsense like that Nick Nick Adderley
and Northampton show also leads a force
that is focused on delivering for for
the public I mean the bureaucratization
of the police the sprawling bureaucracy
of the College of policing you know who
produced these you know lovely uh
enormous tones on on how to uh detect
crime better when in fact the
bureaucracy of the crime detection seems
to be part of the problem as well so
it's not simply about leadership I I
follow lots of police
um social media uh Twitter accounts uh X
whatever it's called
um and it's really interesting when you
look at the ratchet of all this stuff
and the Goths a lot of it that gets
produced by bureaucracies that have been
created with the top to to
um try to support the front line and
what the reality looks like I think what
we have in in stabilities that have the
same resourcing relatively speaking but
are doing much better is a series of
other things happening you've got really
good leadership
uh the second thing that you've got is a
good connection between that leadership
but senior leadership
and Frontline police officers and their
supervisors the sergeants as it were who
you're continuously being under-invested
in uh and they're the driving force of
the policing response you know sergeants
and uh to Electric said inspectors so
where you have
leadership that is focused on supporting
the public uh and driving down crying
and responding to the problems that the
public are talking about and he's got
really good Frontline supervision the
highly motivated staff with the same
resources you can make a big difference
so there's a cultural issue that needs
to be changed
um as well as looking out at the
resource probably on that issue of
culture I mean I wanted to ask you about
the other sort of policing story in the
news this week which is that the head of
the Met Matt Rowley has said that he
doesn't want his offices taking the knee
or sporting political causes anymore
whilst they're on duty I mean do you
think that's the kind of thing do you
support that action
oh absolutely I do support that I think
the police have become mired in uh all
sorts of distracting activities and
virtue signaling uh that that is um you
know almost antithetical to their their
opinion purpose as it were which is to
to to solve trying to protect the public
uh policing shouldn't be politicized
we've seen we've seen the damage that
politicized policing can uh can cause
you know across the board uh including
you know most recently in Northern
Ireland
um where police officers Junior police
officers have thrown on with the bus by
a psni leadership that was cowed by uh
you know Shin fein's um uh demands for
for the scalps of of these officers so
you know I need we need to check profits
completely out of policing a lot of
includes identity politics it all
includes all all other forms of
um virtue signaling we need to get back
to basics to use that Infamous phrase
with the police are simply involved to
protect the public and to solve crime uh
yeah and it's a complex World it may
yeah I do have sympathy when you're
telling people you know the highest
level ever recorded police recorded
crime seven seven billion crimes over
the last recorded year I I don't
underestimate the difficulty that uh
Chief officers have but I find it very
refreshing when you've got people
exchanging warps and coming to uh
greatham abstract police which was in
special measures I mean
in in one case because it was failing
even to record clients don't do anything
about basically they're grabbing that
organization by the Scruff of the neck
and saying we're about getting out there
and uh policing four people and solving
the problems that uh you know people are
concerned about and people's concerned
about identity politics I think it's
very low on the register compared to
their concern about you know high crime
and and particularly anti-social
behavior and incivility which is all off
often the the precursor in communities
that have lost Authority for much
greater crimes so you know people like
that of my respect and support uh
because they you know they will restore
policing to to the model or that I've
described
and finally Kate Andrews says that Brits
don't see their GP enough she writes
Kate joins me now Kate thank you for
joining us on Spectators TV hi John
um you're right in the magazine this
week about the fact that Brits don't
seem to want to go to the doctors I mean
when did you first notice this was going
on so
observation a very very long time ago
um when it struck me that none of my
friends uh it wasn't simply that they
weren't going to the GP for routine
things it was that when they were in
serious pain they were still avoiding
the GP at all costs I think I discovered
this at University when I was at St
Andrews which is well over a decade ago
now uh just like that absolute refusal
to go to the GP and I thought well maybe
it's just like a student thing and I'm
maybe a bit weird that I I might
prioritize going to the doctor when I'm
obviously sick and need medication but
then I discovered Noah every single age
group this appears to be the case and in
our 20s my friends would say well you
know GP appointments are rare they're
rationed we shouldn't be taking up that
space
um and then you know you find yourself
in the workforce you find yourself
needing people from all different
backgrounds all walks of life at all
ages and you discover that people in
their 60s and 70s are also avoiding the
GP in theory to make space for others so
who's going and
um my feeling is is that this isn't
simply about lack of access to treatment
although that's a very serious issue
right now and has been even before the
pandemic but I think there is a genuine
aversion that Brits have to seeking out
Medical Care and I think actually in in
some respects the pandemic has been an
excuse for some people to you know say
well I simply can't go so because they
don't like the doctors or they're
worried about you not like the doctor so
there was some polling done in 2018 so
again long before the pandemic that
found that roughly two-thirds of Brits
would put off medical appointments
because they didn't want to get bad news
so a genuine sense of fear and look you
can ask like what came first this this
nervousness or the NHS telling them not
to show up
um but you know and I I suppose this is
kind of a vicious circle but if you
don't have a system that gives you
preventative kinds of Health Care and
really only sees you when you are very
sick well then it's quite natural that
you're afraid to go to the doctor
because you are afraid to get bad news
because things may have progressed past
a point where maybe if you caught it
earlier things would be slightly better
I list some examples of the in the piece
of things that just absolutely baffle me
um and uh you know I also point out this
isn't part of this is the American in me
um I'm sure you know Americans like to
consume health care but uh I think I
have the rest of the world backing me up
on this one too I think Britain's
neighbors I think virtually all
developed countries look at the UK and
are baffled because on the one hand
everyone in the UK holds up universal
access to health care is this like
crowning Jewel of Britain and yeah its
residents do everything they can to stay
away from that Universe so-called to
universal access I mean you mentioned
that this sort of Affliction has even
affected people in the office can you
tell us a bit about that yeah um I have
quite a few examples in the piece all of
which I got permission for because
they're all proud of this Brits are
proud of the fact that they don't go to
the doctor so they're like yeah I
actually had a colleague be like can you
add me in and I'm like sure okay yeah
I'd love another crazy example
um but uh one one that I do point out is
a colleague of ours and a good friend of
mine had a bug bite and I kept saying to
her you have to go get this checked out
because it's getting worse and
eventually I send her to my private GP
because I was like you just have to go
get this go get the scene immediately
and I should say The Spectator
thankfully offers health insurance so
this is a realistic thing that I was was
able to say to her that certainly isn't
true for everybody
um and she went and and she was hours
away from potentially being hospitalized
it had got so bad and had become so
infected and I think it was widely
agreed in the office and amongst our
friends that she timed it perfectly but
that is when she should have gone and
like we had been having this
conversation for a week but I as I say
I'll I'll take the small one very good
it's a small win maybe lessons could be
learned down the line
I would have to say as well one thing
that really blew my mind in your piece
that really took me back was the fact
that you said you tried to book in for a
GP just for a health check yeah is that
is that a normal thing in America to do
it's a normal thing everywhere John it's
a normal thing everywhere the idea of
going for a preventative check when
you're healthy like just to make sure
that you are still healthy that there
aren't like little things you should be
tackling now so in 30 years they're
dealt with
um yeah they're just going once a year
to get like a very quick little routine
check is is very normal in other
countries and and like I feel in the UK
it's a mind-blowing concept and I I mean
it is funny it's also heartbreaking I
say in the piece this horrifies me
because I'm like what are we gonna
discover in 10 15 years time
um so you know it's I don't know I I've
I'm such a Critic of the American system
as well as the NHS I've never been a fan
of either
um and I I do point out the the law in
America of course is that they have some
pretty terrible Health outcomes compared
to other developed countries and that's
often because people want to see a
doctor but can't because they're afraid
of the cost and in this country these
days you know a lot of people struggle
to see a doctor but even before that I
just don't think a lot of people want to
see a doctor and so you just you end up
getting
um that you you end up getting diagnoses
that just come far later down the line
and become a much bigger problem these
are all like very serious issues but I
can't help but like laugh and also cry
at my friends when you know in theory in
the UK the cost isn't supposed to be
prohibitive and yet people won't go as
you know it's pretty impossible to get a
doctor's appointment at the moment the
health services pretty much on its knees
do you think do you think the problem is
going to get worse now oh absolutely I
think it's gonna get I think it's gonna
get worse a lot of people do want to see
a doctor right now can't and as I say in
the piece if if you do if you're lucky
enough to get that GP appointment in a
reasonable time frame then you have the
prospect of being added to a 7.6 million
person waiting list on NHS England you
can understandably come to the
conclusion what's the point uh and you
know in this country private healthcare
is so expensive there's no competitive
system uh that I I you know that's just
not going to be a realistic option for a
lot of people uh my fear however is that
for others this will essentially
allow them to let their fear take over
and say well I can't see one anyway I'm
not going to try and as I said this
predates the pandemic this I mean I I
think I noticed it pretty soon after I
came to the UK as a student I mean
Freights just don't want to go to the
doctor so
um I I I worry that it's kind of a it's
feeding that fear that they're still not
going to go brilliant thank you very
much Kate thank you John thank you
that's it for this week once again if
you enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss an episode
thank you again for watching and do join
us again next week
[Music]